you've talked about money as morality
too um how do you think about moral
and immoral action in the context of
money um
there's this great great quote by
rothbard
who's a famous austrian economist and he
says quote to be moral
an act must be free
unquote and
you know i think morality it changes
over time and it is
it has its roots in biology
um jordan peterson makes the point that
even animals have their own
sort of pseudomorality where like uh
with wolf packs for instance if there's
a dispute between the alpha males
or i guess between an alpha male and a
incumbent
the two males will have a you know
a fight basically and then when one
it's decided that one has won the loser
will basically roll over and give up his
neck
to uh the alpha male and and
they do this instead of fighting to the
death because
in a wolf pack they need every wolf so
they can go out and bring down
you know you never know when you're
gonna need the 20th wolf to bring down
the big buffalo the next day or whatever
so they've developed this less than
fight to the death
social morality to optimize their
effectiveness as a wolf pack
and art similarly for humans like our
morality sort of emerges
through competition and play even it
there are these
implicit rules that come into place
based on
how we're organizing ourselves over time
and with so
with money it's interesting because most
tools we would consider to be amoral
as in you know a hammer can be used to
build a house
which could be seen to be good like a
good constructive purpose or
could be used to bash someone's skull
which could be something evil
and that the the tool itself is amoral
doesn't have any independent morality of
its own
all of the morality is associated with
the wielder of the tool
so what's the quote like any tool can be
a weapon if you hold it right
sort of thing but money's um
maybe a little bit different in that
when you monopolize money
it's only useful as a tool for one thing
and that's for allocating wealth away
from some and to others
so it is the only utility of monopolized
money is theft
there's no other you know that there's a
lot of propaganda out there that will
say oh we need to print money to get out
of this disaster
or to give to the poor whatever this
whatever
moralistically camouflaged political aim
is being discussed
at the the base layer of monopolized
money is that it's only useful for
taking from some and giving to others
so another way to think about this is
that
money is a paper claim on the savings of
society
so it is just a ticket for redeeming
savings which could be
time could be capital it could be
knowledge from any market actor in the
world
so it's kind of a list of who owns what
if you will it's a proxy list if there's
one group that
can amend that list and others cannot
then they're basically able and incented
to
modify that list to their own benefit
and that's effectively what a central
bank is doing so a central bank
is determining how much money to create
they're also determining who gets to
receive that money first
and the first recipients of that money
are going to be the beneficiaries
in an inflationary regime so those that
receive the money last are the ones
being robbed
those who receive the money first are
the ones that are
uh receiving the stolen proceeds let's
say
and this has a really
corrosive effect on social morality
because
if we consider that people's
time horizon which the austrians call
the time preference
the more short-term thinking you are the
more likely you are to engage
in selfish behavior right if you know
that it's all over tomorrow
you've been working your whole life to
develop you know this business or create
this reputation or whatever your thing
is but you just
are given the foreknowledge that
tomorrow it's all going to end
you're much more likely to go out and
just maybe get drunk and party that
night because
there's no more repercussions right
whereas if you know that you're going to
live for a very long time
you're much more likely to plan for the
future
and money is very so we just say that
that
your time horizon is closely related to
your morality right the
longer term thinking you are the more
moral you would tend to behave the more
you would care about long-term
relationship building
versus going out and getting wasted and
money too
impinges very closely on our time
preference
uh again time preference is the austrian
term so low time preference means
you're long term oriented high time
preference means you're short-term
oriented which can be a little trippy
for some people
because it sounds backwards but um
if your money constantly loses value
you are incentivized to become more
short-term oriented
you are handicapped in your ability to
plan for the future
because your money which is
intended to be here's another definition
of money as an insurance policy against
uncertainty
so no matter what problems you encounter
in the world this money will best help
you deal with those problems
when that insurance policy against
uncertainty is injected
with uncertainty it's polluted with the
uncertainty of inflation
your time horizon shrinks your ability
to plan long-term shrinks
and this impinges on social morality so
there's a great book on this called
honest money by gary north
and in that book he gives the parable of
the winemaker
the winemaker if we just imagine the
hypothetical winemaker
operating a business in a centrally
banked economy
and let's say his central bank just
doubled the money supply to quote
unquote save the economy
say an increase in money supply from one
to two trillion dollars
this wine maker that's accustomed to
selling wine at 20 a bottle
is now faced with basically three
choices
um and an important point here to you
before we get into history choices are
what prices are themselves
prices are the most visible aspect of
any service
so when you increase prices you are
incentivizing your customers to look
elsewhere
they're going to look at your
competition when you decrease prices
you're instant advising
market actors to look closer at your
product right you're delivering a
solution at a lower price
so this wine maker that's accustomed to
selling his wine at a 20
price point all of a sudden because of
his central bank has tripled the money
supply
he has three choices he can either
keep selling his bottle at 20 and all of
his inputs will increase
due to inflation by 50 so he will
lose 50 of his profit margin as a result
uh so he can choose to eat that loss he
can choose to double the selling price
of his bottle of wine from twenty
dollars to forty dollars because all of
the price of
his inputs doubled so then he would
maintain his profit margin
or the third one is that he could choose
to water down his wine
or use inferior ingredients so he could
use cheaper inputs
and maintain the output at the same
price
so he could basically start selling his
customers an inferior product for the
same price to preserve his profit margin
now again case number one it's not very
palatable
he doesn't want to eat the economic loss
case number two it's not very good
either
because he's then incentivizing all of
his customers to go shop other
winemakers if he doubles his price
so human nature being what it is trying
to get something for nothing
inflation actually seeps into other
industries by encouraging producers
into option three which is to deceive
your customer in the short run and again
this would
be done initially at the margins maybe
it's just a few drops of water maybe
it's just
some cheaper grapes but over time
[Music]
this inflation is actually inducing
producers to weigh
their financial well-being against their
moral integrity
so it's forcing them into this dilemma
that would not exist
in a free market economy and
as they charge more money for wine that
is inferior
the buyers of that wine also living in a
central bank economy are also getting
scammed
by not only the inflation but also the
wine so it becomes this kind of
corrosive
contagious moral effect
that propagates throughout an economy
and
that's why i've argued in a lot of my
writing that inflation is this
infectious moral cancer on the world
i think it is tied back to a lot of the
the social strangeness we've seen in
modern times
where you know there seems to be a lot
of fake people and a lot of fake
businesses and a lot of scams all of
these things i think it really is rooted
in the money
and you know bitcoin as the first money
in history that has a zero percent
terminal inflation rate or
said differently zero unexpected
inflation there's no
there's no theft integrated into bitcoin
you can only earn it through work or
sacrificing resources to obtain it
um it r it is the antidote to this moral
cancer
uh that inflation riddles our society
with
again you're blowing my mind a little
bit to think about the ripple effects of
inflation
the the way it seeps through our
interactions
so at the very the early ripples
is the effect it has on the products on
the the dilution of the wine
but also it might have uh ripple effects
on the character on the behavior of
people
that's interesting artificial creation
of scarcity creating um
having effects on society at the social
like the social fabric
yeah i guess you're arguing the morality
it's perverting free market dynamics
which again we said free markets
generate pragmatic truth
so inflation distorts price signals
which means it confuses capital
allocation
yeah so we're trying to solve problems
but all of a sudden we can't tell if
this price increase is a matter of
true supply and demand change or a
matter of policy change
so it it clouds our economic perceptions
uh it suppresses innovation because now
you've you've exacerbated the boom and
bust business cycle people are going to
overborrow
and go into projects that they can't
profitably sustain so then it'll be a
huge collapse
so that actually breaks um the the
market's function of generating
innovation
and then yeah i would argue too that it
pollutes our are
our pursuit of virtue let's say maybe
it's pushing back
but i don't think so i'm it's not as
clear to me
perhaps because i haven't thought about
it deeply that money is
core to life and human interaction
because there might be other forces
other fraudulent forces other things
in human nature that are creating these
effects as well
so it's clear i think you're
articulating really well that there's
these negative effects from
inflation i wonder if there's other
undiscovered
not undiscovered but ones we're not
making explicit now forces that are
creating
the you know all the things we're seeing
now with like you said cancer culture
and all those things
but also the negative effects
on the on the quality of products and
the excellence
of the creativity and the innovation all
those kinds of things i wonder if
there's other factors
it's it's kind of listen um it's
compelling to
think money's at the core of it all
right like if you fix
i forgot what the phrase was right the
money fix the world yeah fix the money
fix the world
that uh again
things that sound good i'm skeptical of
by nature
so i wonder if there's other things that
are beyond money
that are somehow deeply integrated into
our human nature another one
related to money is social cohesion
itself
so very simple anecdote for this was
the more you increase the inflation rate
social cohesion is inversely
proportionate to that so the extreme
example would be hyperinflation
right where the money is produced in
such excess that it loses all meaning
and relevance
so today in venezuela there is cash
clogging the gutters clogging the
streets clogging the sewer system
because the cash has lost all relevance
and so anecdotally we would suspect that
okay if there's a
inverse relationship between inflation
and social cohesion
if we could then take inflation to zero
couldn't we theoretically increase
social cohesion to its maximum
so another way to say that is inflation
is a de-civilizing force
whereas natural price deflation which
would occur
in a hard money economy where there's
either a fixed supply of bitcoin
or a relatively scarce supply of gold
for instance
that lays claim to a to an increasing
capital stock
of goods and services prices would
naturally decline every year as we
became smarter
so the market price becomes a reflection
of our collective knowledge
so by letting prices decline naturally
over time we can actually
induce civilization but by trying to
force prices higher all the time via the
central bank
we're creating the opposite effect
you